destrucción total es lo que se percibe
al tiempo que las fuerzas contra
incendios arrebatan cada vez más espacio
a las llamas una bandera ondea como
símbolo de esperanza ante las
consecuencias que puede acarrear el
accidente industrial la falta de
combustible augura unos días difíciles
gracias te puede ser que sea de alguna
repercusión
pero no es una repercusión tan grande
existe una afectación tan tan grande
pero puede ser un poco de afectación por
respetuoso y es que el siniestro más
devastador que ha vivido la isla provocó
la salida de una de las termoeléctricas
más importantes del país el impacto que
tiene es terrible porque la en última
instancia la economía funciona para la
gente y había una situación de
estándares de vida
deteriorados no sólo te digo no solo por
los problemas que tiene estructurales la
economía cubana en primer lugar sino
porque a nivel mundial tenía una
situación de incremento significativo de
los precios del petróleo y también un
incremento significativo de los precios
de los alimentos en una economía que
depende mucho de importaciones el
embargo económico de los eeuu es también
un factor importante sobre la mesa no
obstante los sucedidos matanzas es un
llamado de atención para que el gobierno
acelere lo que debe ser cambiado en ese
sector este y hace más difícil todavía
el reto de realizar esos cambios pero el
país está abocado a hacerlo y yo creo
que no hay manera de que pueda evitar
ese camino mientras tanto al cuerpo de
bomberos con la ayuda de expertos
mexicanos y venezolanos luchan contra el
último embate de la conflagración